Рік тому - 11 червня 2017-го - між Україною та ЄС почав діяти безвізовий режим.
Які зміни приніс Києву омріяний безвіз?
Після запровадження безвізу українці стали частіше подорожувати до Європи.
За даними Держприкордонслужби,
за останній рік без віз до країн Шенгену з’їздили понад півмільйона громадян.
Найчастіше подорожували до ЄС через Польщу.
Відмови на в'їзд до країн шенгенської зони отримали лише 1,5 тисячі українців.
Найпоширеніші причини - відсутність необхідних документів
та брак коштів на перебування.
Завдяки безвізу український паспорт опинився у топ-30 найсильніших паспортів світу,
і українці тепер можуть вільно подорожувати без віз у 117 країн.
Завдяки безвізу збільшилася не лише кількість подорожувальників,
але й відкрилися нові можливості для поїздок.
Безвіз зробив Україну привабливішою для бюджетних авіакомпаній.
тож з осені цього року на ринок виходить лоукостер Ryanair,
кількість своїх рейсів з України збільшив також Wizzair.
Крім того, про наміри літати в Україну заявили Eurowings та EasyJet.
Своєю чергою "Укрзалізниця" запустила другий швидкісний потяг
з Києва до польського Перемишля, що значно полегшило життя тим,
хто планує скористатися рейсами лоукостерів, які літають в межах ЄЄ.
Безвізовий режим спростив для українців пошук роботи в Європі.
І хоча безвіз не дає права працювати в ЄС,
громадяни України можуть безпосередньо їздити на співбесіди,
персонально спілкуватися з роботодавцем і знайомитися з умовами роботи в компанії.
На робочу силу з України, зокрема, розраховують у Польщі, Німеччині, Чехії та Словаччині.
Втім, за оцінкою експертів, значно на картину трудової міграції
вільні подорожі до Європи не вплинули.
Натомість, за словами міністра соціальної політики Олександра Реви,
безвіз зменшив безробіття в Україні,
а також змусив роботодавців збільшувати зарплату співробітникам.
Безвіз став вагомим стимулом для реформ в Україні.
Задля нього Київ запровадив електронні декларації для посадовців,
а також були створені інституції для протидії корупції,
на появу яких Україна чекала понад 20 років - Національне антикорупційне бюро,
Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура та Нацагентство із запобігання корупції.
Крім того, українські прикордонники отримали доступ до баз даних Інтерполу
у міжнародних і міждержавних пунктах пропуску
та було поліпшено процедуру виявлення незаконних мігрантів.
Та чи не найважливіший пункт - зміни у свідомості самих українців.
Побачивши життя в ЄС на власні очі, люди,
особливо старшого віку, отримали шанс змінити своє,
часто хибне, уявлення про Європу, а молодь - стимул до змін у власній країні.